PROFESSOR: So now
we're going to talk
about the concepts of
validity and satisfiability,
which take on some extra
interest in the context
of predicate calculus.
So let's remember for
propositional validity,
if you have a propositional
formula with variables taking
the truth values ranging
over true and false,
then a formula is
valid when it's
true for all possible
truth values.
So here's an example that
P implies Q or Q implies P.
And you can check that for the
four possible environments of P
and Q-- true/false
values of P and Q,
this OR will come
out to be true.
Well, for predicate formulas
there's a bunch of things
that I need to
give value to that
are more complicated
than just truth values.
In particular, I will say that
a predicate calculus formula
is valid when it's true for all
possible domains of discourse
that the variables range over.
There's a technicality that it
has to be non-empty, but aside
from that all possible domains.
And whenever you have
a predicate mentioned
in the formula, in order to
know whether the formula is true
or not, I need to know
what that predicate means.
So a formula is valid if it
comes out true no matter what
the predicate means.
Let's look at a concrete
example to get a grip on this.
Here is a valid formula
of predicate calculus.
It's mentioning
predicates P and Q.
It's of the form
of a proposition
because it's saying something
about every possible z
in the domain and every
possible x and every possible y.
The only thing that we need
to know to make sense out
of this formula, to figure
out whether or not it's true,
is what's the domain that
x, y, and z range over
and what exactly
do P and Q mean?
Well, I want to
argue informally.
Let's just look at what
this is saying together.
What this is saying is
suppose that for everything
in the domain, both
property P of z and P of Q.
In other words, everything
in the domain have property P
and property Q. Well,
that certainly implies
that everything in the
domain has property
P because they have
both properties.
And also, everything
in the domain
has property Q because
everything has both properties.
So when you say it
that way, the sense
that this is a fundamental
logical fact that
doesn't depend on what P and
Q mean or what the domain is.
It's just a fact about the
nature of the meaning of the
for all universal quantifier and
the connectives [? AND then ?]
implies.
That's how we figure
out that this is valid.
Well, let me go one
level in more detail
to say again what I
just said informally
and try to be a little
bit more precise and clear
about a reason why
this formula is valid.
So suppose I wanted to prove
that the formula is valid.
Well, it's an implication.
So the proof strategy--
there it is written again--
the proof strategy is
I'm going to assume
that the if part, the
left-hand side of the implies
or hypothesis, is true.
That is, that for every z, P
of z holds and Q of z holds.
And then I'm going to try
to prove, based on that,
that the consequent
holds, namely
that the right-hand side for all
x P of x and for all y Q of y
holds.
OK.
How am I going to do that?
Well, so here's the
formula written just
to fit on the line with the
concise mathematical symbols.
The upside down V means AND,
and the arrow means implies.
And we want to try to prove that
this is valid a little bit more
carefully.
Well, the strategy,
as I said, is
to assume that the
left-hand side holds.
Well, what's the
left-hand side say?
It says that for every z, Q
of z holds and P of z holds.
That means that for every
possible environment that
assigns a value to
z, Q of z and P of z
both come out to be true.
Well, suppose that the
environment assigns the value c
to z, where c is some
element of the domain.
Then what this means is that in
that environment, Q of z and P
of z is true, which means
that Q of c and P of c holds.
But Q of c holds and P
of c holds, so Q of c
certainly holds all by itself.
All right.
So now we're in an
interesting situation
because we just proved
that Q of c holds.
And we know nothing and
have assumed nothing
about c except that it's
an element of the domain.
c could have been any
element of the domain,
and we've managed to
prove that Q of c holds.
So it follows that, in
fact, we have really proved
that for every x Q of x holds.
Now, that step of saying I
proved it for Q of a given
element without making any
assumptions about the given
element except that it's in
the domain and therefore I can
conclude that it holds
for all domain elements,
[? it's  a ?] very natural and
plausible and understandable
rule.
And it's a basic axiom of
logic called UG-- Universal
Generalization.
We'll come back
to it in a minute.
Anyway, I've just proved
that for all x Q of x holds.
And by a completely symmetric
argument, for all y P of y
holds.
And having proved both for all
x Q of x and for all y P of y,
clearly the AND holds.
And I've just proved
that the right-hand side
of this implication is true
given that the left-hand side
is true.
Now, having called
this proving validity,
let me immediately
clarify that this is not
fair to call a proof because
the rules of the game
are really murky here.
This theorem, you
could read it as saying
that universal quantification
distributes over AND
is one of these
basic valid formulas
that is so fundamental
and intelligible that it's
hard to see what
more basic things
you are allowed to assume
when you're proving it.
And this proof really
isn't anything more
than translating upside down A
and the AND symbol into English
and using ordinary intuitive
rules about for all and AND
and using that in the proof.
So this is a good way to
think about the formula
to get an understanding of it.
But it's not right
to say that it's
a proof because we haven't
been exactly clear about what
the proof rules are.
And with this kind of really
fundamental valid fact,
it becomes a quite
technical problem
to decide what a
proof is going to be.
What's fair to assume and
what's fair not to assume?
It would actually be
perfectly plausible to take
this as an axiom and
then prove other things
as a consequent of it.
Anyway, going on, let's look at
this just for cultural reasons.
We're never going to actually
ask you to do anything with it.
But the universal
generalization rule UG
would be stated this way as
a deduction rule in logic.
The stuff over the bar
means if you've proved this,
then you can conclude you've
proved the stuff below the bar.
So what this is
saying is if you've
proved P of c for
a constant c, then
you can deduce that for
every x P of x holds.
And this is providing
that c does not
occur in any other
part of the predicate P
except where you're talking
explicitly about it.
It's hard to be more
precise about that for now.
Don't worry about it.
But the idea is you're not
supposed to assume anything
about c other than
it's in the domain
and that it has property P,
and you can then conclude
that everything has property P.
So let's look at
a similar example
where it is possible
to prove something.
Namely, I can prove that
something's not valid.
So here's a
similar-looking formula.
This one says that for every
z if P of z holds OR Q of z
holds, then for every x P of
x holds OR for every y Q of y
holds.
And this one we're going
to show is not valid.
Let's think about
it for a minute.
What it's saying is if
everything has either property
P or property Q, that implies
that everything has property P
or everything has property Q.
Well, when you say it that way,
it's clearly not the case.
But let's go one level more
precise and lay that out.
What I'm going to
do is convince you
that it's not valid by giving
you a counter-model where
I choose an interpretation.
I choose a domain of
discourse and predicates
that P and Q are going
to mean over that domain
and that make the left-hand
side of this implication true.
And then I'm going to show you
that the right-hand side is not
true.
And that means
that in that domain
with those interpretations
of P and Q,
this implication fails
so it's not valid.
So I need to make the
left-hand side true
and the right-hand side false.
Well, I'm going to choose
the domain of discourse
to be the simplest one
that will make this false,
namely let's let the domain of
discourse just be the numbers
1 and 2.
And let Q of z be the predicate
that says z is 1 and P of z
be the predicate
that says z is 2.
Well, is the
left-hand side true?
Yeah, because the only things
there are in the domain
are 1 and 2, and so clearly
everything in the domain
is either 1 or 2.
So the antecedent is true.
On the other hand, is
everything in the domain,
does it satisfy P?
Is everything in the
domain equal to 2?
No, 1's not equal to 2.
What about, is everything
in the domain equal to 1?
Is it true that for
all y Q of y holds?
No, 2 is in the domain,
and it's not equal to 1.
And so we have
found exactly what
we wanted, a
counter-model which makes
the left-hand side
of the implies true
and the right-hand side
of the implies false.
Let me close with just one
more example of a valid formula
that we can talk through.
This is the version
of De Morgan's law
that works for quantifiers.
Remember De Morgan's
law was the thing that
said that the negation
of P or Q was the same
as not P and not
Q. And remembering
that the connection between
universal quantification,
[? an ?] AND, and existential
quantification, [? an ?] OR,
it turns out that by the
same kind of reasoning,
De Morgan's law
comes out this way.
It says that if it's
not true that everything
has property P,
that's possible if
and only if there's something
that doesn't have property P.
And so that's what
De Morgan's law is.
It's another thing you
could take as an axiom,
or you could try one of these
hand-waving proofs about.
But I think I've said
enough to give you
that example of another
interesting valid formula,
and we'll stop with that.